Do not wait for Christmas.
Do not wait for Christmas
to buy this hundred and thirty piece magnetic tile set.
Every time I tried to buy these last month,
they were sold out. I mean,
like in under 24 hours. Listen to me.
This set is over hundred dollars at big box stores.
And if you're like me, a stay at home mom
who just wants to give her kids
the best Christmas that she possibly can afford to,
you need to look at this set.
It is 1 hundred and thirty pieces and it is under thirty dollars.
We all wanna be the cool Montessori moms,
you know? You know,
we want our kids brain development to be good.
And those toys are very expensive.
But not these. Because TikTok Shop makes it affordable for us
to give our kids a great educational and fun Christmas.
So yes, I bought these early before Christmas
because these have been on my wish list for over a year.
Because quite frankly, I couldn't afford them until TikTok shop.
Now, the link is right there.
Don't wait, they'll sell out again.